is ck an offset of some hungarian my
grandfather
this gets even worse hungarian who's uh
my hungarian grandfather was jewish and
he left
hungary because holy monster killing the
jews yeah
and he he couldn't come the united
jews going they st letting them they
turned boats away so he went to mexico
and he met my catholic mexican
grandmother and ray that's the
that's the family i came a jew and a
catholic
mexican and he didn't tell her he was
jewish because he was so in love with
her
ck is my first two hot letters of your
whole life it's pronounced
do you want to take so much longer
thing i do know where the term kite came
from by the way
ah derogatory terms i do know where that
came from where
it is when that when people used to come
uh over on the uh
you know in the ships that on ellis
island
a lot of people couldn't write english
so they used to make their mark and the
jews mark was a circle
and uh the circle is called kaikal so
that's what
they were just showing it to [__] the
guys here's another kite once they've
seen the
the circle you know where [__] came
from
originally there was some black guy
being a [__]
[Laughter]
he was being a real [__] and somebody
said what a [__] and that's where it
started
[__] was a feeling yeah he's just like
this
yeah it wasn't some word playing just
blurting out a sound that it came out
like
just the guy was being such a [__]
that he [__] made someone say the
word
oh my god man we were learning about
derogatory terms and where they came
from right wow
it's history it's a really good history
lesson i never knew that
i say hi to jesse jesse what's up